欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,第六章节我们来讲一下
怎样去构建
寻盘高转化的系统
也就是我们要去把店铺的基础做好
通过从这几个维度去把店铺基础做好
让我们的店铺的
寻盘转化率更高
让我们在后期
直动的推广
或者是在产品优化的时候
更加简单,更加有效
那么接下来我们会从
关键词, 标题, 还有产品, 还有产品商业, 选词等多个维度去搭建一个良好的店铺基础
那么接下来我们先看第一小节, 什么是关键词, 我们怎么样去确定我们的关键词, 词根
我们都知道关键词是流量的源头, 是链接产品和买家的一个中间的桥料
因为买家是通过关键词来找产品的
我们的产品的精准比配给买家也是通过关键词的
所以说这是一个决定着我们的产品跟买家是否精准比配
是否能够有效的获得高质量寻盘的一个非常重要的源头
那么如果你不懂关键词是很难做好店铺的
以及你的直通车推广可能会导致浪费大量的预算
因为很多人在选词和对词的精准性的判断上有很大的误差
所以说就会导致它寻盘不精准或者是推广浪费大量的钱
那么接着我们来看一下具体什么是关键词
关键词就是我们产品的中心词
是产品服务的具体名称
比如说我们的产品名称是T恤
手机, 还有电视机, 等等这些都是产品的名称, 都是产品的关键词, 那么服务是指哪些呢, 比如说人家有些是做物流的, 就有空运, 海运, 这些就是服务, 也是一种关键词, 那么这些关键词是对产品的一种描述, 是客户通过用产品的专属词, 来表达他对某一种产品的需求, 比如说客户搜索关键词A, 那么A匹配的,
产品是B,就代表着客户通过, 想通过这个关键词来找到产品B, 就是这样的一个逻辑
第二个就是词根有多重要, 我们很多人都忽视了词根的重要, 词根如果你找的对, 而且找的全, 那么你去覆盖的整个行业, 或者是整个品类的关键词就会非常的全
你的店铺里面的流量的覆盖范围就非常的广
所以说一定要学会去理解这个词根和拓展出更多的词根去挖掘更多的关键词
比如说T恤产品是不是它有三种词都是对T恤进行描述的
是不是都是在表达同一种产品
但是呢这三个词放在关键词指数里面去搜索的时候
会出现不同的匹配类型,那么不同的这种词根去拓展出来的关键词
它只有少部分是重复的,大部分是不重复的
所以说你通过这三个关键词词根去找到跟这些词根相关的所有的词
然后把这些词全部用于组合标题,那么我们店铺就能够覆盖大量的流量了
这个词根是拓展关键词的一个重要的支点
那么等一下我们去后台进行一个演示
第三个就是怎么样确定我们的产品词根呢
通过每一个类产品确定出这个品类的所有的相关产品的名称
我们直接来看一下这个例子
比如说这个T恤拓展出这个也是T恤
这个也是T恤你看单复数大小写
都是不同的一个词根, 这些都可以有不同的形式, 那么我们在收词根的时候, 搜索出来的时候, 刚才我们这里也讲了, 它部分是相同的, 大部分是不相同的, 那么我们怎么样去找这些词根呢?
首先我们就是通过我们的中文的关键词去找,比如说我们输入T恤中文,在这里翻译,翻译的时候它会出现多种英文的形式,比如说这种多种英文的形式,这种英文的形式之后我们就去关键词搜索指数,以及阿里前台搜索一下,看看是否跟我们的产品匹配一致,如果匹配一致,那么我们就可以用这些词去拓展出更多我们的
用于去发产品, 覆盖更多的流量, 提升我们整个店铺的流量的覆盖度, 那么我们直接到后台来看一下, 比如说我们要找池根是吧, 我们首先自己先打开一个不尽量的首页, 我们在这个类目里面看, 这个类目里面看, 我们你看, 这是二级类目, 这是一级类目, 这是二级类目, 二级类目里面, 这些基本都算是一些池根, 比如说, 纸盒,
这些是词根, 你点进去之后, 它就会显示一个纸盒, 看到没有, 纸盒是一个词根, 我们这个词根的话, 我们来这里关键词, 指数这里收, 你来这里收, 收, 搜索, 再看一下, 看到了吗, 它会出现很多相关的, 跟这个纸盒相关的所有的词都在这个里面呢, 我们选择的时间是近30天, 选择终端这些都不选, 那么它所有的词都是跟这个纸盒相关的,
这就是我们的拓展词根,比如说刚才我们的是纸盒的话,是这个叫做纸盒, 我们把它的中文写下来, 纸盒写在这里, 写在这里的时候出现的是纸盒, 那么我们把这个词拿到国际站首页去搜, 一搜出来发现它的纸盒跟我们产品的纸盒是不一样的, 那么我们就不能用这个词去发我们的产品,
或者是说你这个词要跟别的词,比如说别的词组合之后,如果是我们的产品,比如说我们在这里收,把这个词作为词根进来收,收了之后你去看哪些词跟我们刚才说的那个纸盒是相关的,那么才是有效的词,如果是不相关的,那么我们都不能把这个词作为词根,这是一种方法,比如说我刚才讲的那个T恤,我在这里收T恤,
你看这里出现的是这几种形式, 看到没有, 这几种形式的话我去, 我一个个去复制去, 在这里收, 这样拓展出所有的池根, 这个是相关的, 在这里收一下是不是跟我们的产品相关, 这个都是跟我们产品相关的, 这个说明这个就可以作为池根, 作为池根的话我们把这整个相关的池全部导出来, 这就是一个池根拓展出来的,
这么多相关词, 第二个词根呢, 比如说我们, 你看这个是不一样的是吧, 那么我们再去复制, 把它复制进来, 看看它能不能拓展出一些关键词, 你看, 这个词也能拓展出很多关键词是吧, 那么我们再看一下这个词是不是我们的产品的相关的词, 也是我们的产品相关词, 所以说这个词作为词根, 这个词也可以作为词根, 这个也是一样的道理, 你按照这种思路去拓展就可以了, 那么这个的话,
就是我们拓展词的, 比如说电视机, 我们可以拓展出这几个关键词, 那么我们就要自己去搜, 我们常用的是哪些词, 在这个关键词指数里面去搜, 同时在这里面去搜, 搜出来之后, 我们就确定哪个作为词根之后, 我们就把这些数据相关的词导出来就可以了, 那么我们的词根它都是有一个比较特殊的,
特征的,它很短,可能是一个单词,有可能是两个单词,基本就可以作为词根了,因为你只有短的词,才能够拓展出更多相关的词,是吧,那么我们在找词的时候,就重点找这些词去拓展,才能够覆盖到更多的关键词,那么这节课我们就主要是讲什么是关键词,以及怎么样去确定词根和找到
更多的词根去挖掘更多的关键词, 把我们整个品类或者是某个行业里面的某类产品的所有的词都能够挖掘出来去途合标题, 覆盖更多的关键词
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里, 具体的话可以根据后台去操作, 或者是根据你们自己的产品去进行一个词操